мало того що це великою мірою бюджет не
війни а фігні тому що ми бачимо там знов
марафони барабани серіали і все інше то
це ще і бюджет шулерства шулерства друзі
не я конкретний приклад наводжу стаття
восьма проекту закону
передбачає нагадаю що в нас мінімальна
зарплата зростає до 7100 грн з 1 січня і
8,000 грн з 1 квітня і тут же в тому ж
абзаці сказано що для розрахунку
величини обчислення виплат за рішенням
суддів А це важливо наприклад для
чорнобильців для деяких інших категорій
враховувати не 8 000 а 1600 грн тобто
штучно в п'ять разів занижаємо виплати
наприклад чорнобильцям Що про це думає
голова Житомирської обласної організації
слуги народу пускаренко